[Music]
thank you for joining this is rocky nash
and we are talking today with bianca
holman for fitness
week hey bianca hey rocky hey everybody
so as you all may or may not know it's
fitness week so
every morning at 6 a.m they're talking
about what we do
what you do to stay healthy and bianca i
hear it's on a
plant-based diet yes well you know what
i call myself a flexitarian
okay because um throughout the week i'm
mostly plant-based
um and then you know if i go out to a
nice restaurant or you know i'm having a
celebration with friends i will have
you know maybe some fish or something
like that or turkey or something like
that something light
so that's why i say i'm more of a
flexitarian
than full out plant-based but yeah so
it's been a journey
journey that i started researching
several years ago after a health
situation and
just found all the benefits and it's an
up and deal
uphill and downhill type journal it's
never perfect it's never straight and
linear but
there's so many more resources now than
there were years ago so
it's a lot easier right well you're
glowing
it must
but if you all have experience with that
or you've been considering going
plant-based or anything put
your experiences in the comments and
share them with us also be sure to
follow bianca
on social media i'm going to share
that's all right yeah okay we're going
to go to instagram really quickly so you
can see
we got to have fun with this so i've
made some videos just let y'all know
i've made some
you know tick tock videos i've tried to
you know keep up with the kids
so i've made some tick tock videos just
kind of documenting my journey
and just sharing with people that you
know it can be fun it takes a little bit
of research but there's so many
resources out there you can go to
youtube to find recipes
there's so many different restaurants i
mean y'all i'm coming from southwest
virginia this is where i was before at
another station
and we have so many plant-based options
so many restaurants accommodate your
various eating
unique habits that you have and
requirements that you have so
i mean when you start looking you will
now have an open eyes
have your eyes open to all the different
options that are out there
well your experience is going to help us
because i wouldn't even know where to
start so thank you for posting these
yeah here we go this is just like a day
in my life so i usually start out with a
green smoothie
a little snack i think that's like a
little southwest
uh type of potato dish i made with a
side of veggies and then for dinner i
had a salad and
soup and a little toast everything you
see there is plant-based so they have
plant-based butters they've got
you know plant-based anything breads
all that kind of stuff that you can
imagine and you can take a dish that you
usually have whether it's tacos pasta
anything and make it plant-based if you
wanted to there's so many different
alternatives so you can use
mushrooms as a meat alternative nuts as
a meat alternative beans
of course there's soy products and all
that kind of stuff so
yeah there's so many different options
once you start researching and a lot of
disease especially in the black
community whether it's
high blood pressure diabetes it's
lifestyle
diseases and so when you find out hey if
i can change the way i eat
i can live longer i can stay out of the
hospital i can you know
rather than spending money on insulin
you can spend that money you know
on healthy foods um but it is a
challenge right because you got to find
time to meal plan
you got to change some habits your
family going to look at you crazy like
what
you don't know burgers no this know that
they going to look at you crazy no
chicken wings for the
for dinner like but it does when you
when you understand the benefits of it i
mean it's worth the sacrifice so that's
why i say i'm a flexitarian i do
indulge a little bit but very very
sparingly uh compared to
you know what i used to do for sure
thank you for sharing we're gonna share
one more
okay all right and shout out to vegan's
baby
uh diana edelman she has a vlog where
she was profiling and
is profiling so many different vegan
options and plant-based options in the
valley
so when i tell you there are so many
restaurants tacoterian which is downtown
they have two locations
there's one called garden grill which is
in the northwest part of the valley that
has
if you're craving a fried chicken
sandwich okay this one has you beat
popeyes in chick-fil-a they have a
nashville hot chicken sandwich at a
garden grill so when you want to you
know indulge a little bit
and have something a little fattening or
um you know that is a little bit you
know
off the beaten path of a salad right
we're not eating salads all day
but uh so they have a great option there
and really fun there's so there's even
vegan sushi
y'all yes vegan okay we're gonna have to
put a list of the places that bianca
recommends on the website go ahead
newsnow.com and we'll be posting
her recommendations you can get creative
once you once you start kind of
connecting with folks
you know social media is our best friend
and there's so many different recipes so
many people out there figuring it out
tabitha brown she's everybody's mama
right you know her on
on um on tick tock she got famous on tik
tok and so she decided to go plant-based
because of a health concern
and she noticed the change so if you are
having ailments
you know going more plant-based and
getting rid of a lot of inflammatory
foods can help
you you know it helps you sleep better
it helps your your waistline
that's secondary but it helps your
waistline too um
and so we are what we eat you know if
you whatever you put in your body is
gonna come out some kind of way so
um it's worth the sacrifice and you're
gonna fall off the wagon a little bit
but you can always get back on
yeah thanks for the pepsi i'm trying to
encourage y'all
who needed that event we're going to
share one more but you're going to
follow
bianca on instagram at bianca h media
here we go
see this is me having fun because again
you may get tired of salads a little bit
but you gotta be
creative start with you know something
simple and uh you know work your way up
it doesn't have to be oh i gotta go in
and throw out
all of my you know the items with me
or dairy he's into it you know maybe you
instead of getting skim milk you get oat
milk or you get
almond milk or soy milk whatever there's
so many different alternatives
and that's something how i started i
just started by changing out my milk
and then i started okay let me change
out my butters let me you know
incorporate more mushrooms let me
go meatless monday so there's so many
different alternatives
everyone stay tuned keep following
bianca's journey we want to support her
help her on this path and and the story
will be posted all over social media and
on our website
newsnow.com thank you all right thank
you y'all take care